what is Trump's message this whole world
is on fire this world is on fire before
I even arrive at the Oval Office I will
have the horrible war between Russia and
Ukraine totally settled I'll have it
done in 24 hours
as the Bible says blessed are the
peacemakers see that and I will be your
Peacemaker I was your Peacemaker very
conservative message and it's also a
very unusual message for the last 30
years I guess of the GOP the GOP message
has been a little more saber-rattling
it's been a little bit more we're going
to go in there we're going to bomb them
we're going to spread Freedom around the
world you're with us or against us we're
gonna go attack the axis of Evil spread
democracy wipe out these different bad
guys around the world what could
possibly go wrong Trump is saying I'm
Gonna Be Your Peacemaker blessed are the
peacemakers I'm going to be a peacemaker
in politics